Figaro live bonjour on est en direct ce
matin pour continuer de à parler de ce
qui se passe en Ukraine je suis ce matin
avec Alexis ferchak adjoint au pôle Actu
du Figaro bonjour Alexis on va décrypter
grâce aux cartes du service infographie
toute la situation sur place qui évolue
très rapidement bien sûr tout au soleil
vous n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos
questions on est sur YouTube sur
Facebook sur la page d'accueil du Figaro
on peut peut-être commencer à à poser
une question un peu général c'est
justement comment évolue la situation en
Ukraine de façon générale la manière
extrêmement brève en fait il y a trois
fronts il y a un front au nord de
l'Ukraine à fond à l'Est un fond au sud
et il se passe un événement principal à
la fois au nord à l'est et au sud au
nord c'est les convois de blindés qui
s'étendait parfois sur 60 km
à Kiev et qui peuvent préfigurer une une
prochaine
vraiment offensive massive contre Kiev
pour l'instant elle n'a pas commencé et
les troupes sont à l'arrêt c'est ce qui
a déclaré le Pentagone à l'aise vous
avez la deuxième ville du pays
et là en fait des troupes aéroportés
russes les VDV
ont débarqué à carquif
donc sa préfigure une grande grosse
offensive sachant que la ville est très
défendue et c'est vraiment une bataille
très importante et puis au sud vous avez
une ville portuaire qui est aussi
essentiel elle est à l'embouchure du
Nièvre le niAme c'est vraiment le grand
fleuve qui traverse
du nord au sud l'Ukraine et c'est la
ville de Kerson et visiblement elle
aurait été prise par les Russes ou
quasiment prises c'est important c'est
symbolique parce que c'est la première
grande ville dont la Russie s'empare
véritablement effectivement on va
rentrer un peu dans les détails de ces
trois fronts ces trois villes la ville
dont on parle le plus ce matin c'est
cariffe effectivement quartier il faut
les combats sont les plus importants
pour l'instant absolument alors c'est le
karkip c'est vraiment quasiment la
frontière avec la Russie oui on le voit
sur la carte il y a 30 km à tout casser
avec les la front et c'est là où il y a
énormément de défense ukrainiennes et
donc c'est depuis le début c'est là où
les conflits sont les combats sont
vraiment les les plus violents et ce
qu'on a vu hier et qui est assez
terrible c'est notamment l'usage de
l'artillerie qui est extrêmement
prononcé et ça fait évidemment des des
morts civils d'énormes destructions et
là on entre dans des combats
urbain c'est à dire que pendant les ces
derniers jours les combats étaient
surtout abords de car kiffe là on a des
probablement des para qu'on qu'on était
consultés sur kerkip donc ça sera
rapproche de la ville elle-même et avec
ça les risques humanitaires que ça
laisse courir et juste parce que ça
c'est un exemple il y a probablement un
changement de de stratégie russe mais ça
on va en reparler jusqu'à présent les
Russes
était assez mesuré sur l'emploi de
l'artillerie de l'aviation etc et comme
ils ont du mal enfin ils ont du mal il
rencontre une résistance beaucoup plus
importante que prévu face aux Ukrainiens
il semblerait que les Russes est quand
même changé de fusil d'épaule si je puis
dire et qu'ils ont reviennent à une
tactique beaucoup plus
forte et puissante voilà donc avec
beaucoup de tirs d'artillerie dans la
ville de carcif c'est ça qui est
absolument on a vu des images vraiment
terribles contre des immeubles
d'habitation y compris justement c'est
des vignières routines disaient qu'ils
ne visait pas ici que c'était forcément
des opérations très ciblées là les
images viennent contredire directement
ce qu'il dit en tout cas ces images oui
très clairement après ils n'ont pas que
par ailleurs les Russes sont réalisés
des des frappes ciblées depuis le début
des opérations
mais là il y a un recours beaucoup plus
puissant à la à l'artillerie et
notamment au lance-roquettes multiples
qui ne sont pas très précis par
définition alors on a une autre question
alors c'est sur un autre front on va
parler maintenant c'est c'est Kiev yoga
qui nous demande pourquoi Kiev n'est
toujours pas sous le contrôle russe
sachant que on disait vendredi dernier
je me rappelle que la ville pourrait
tomber dans les prochaines heures et
finalement c'est pas forcément ce qui
s'est passé alors déjà attention quand
on dit qu'on pensait que les Russes
allaient s'emparer le l'Ukraine en une
journée ou en deux jours
les spécialistes étaient quand même plus
mesurés on l'a déjà dit mais on le
répète c'est un pays qui est plus grand
que la France 600 000
km², il y a 40 millions d'habitants
c'est le plus grand pays d'Europe or
Russie donc même s'il y a une
supériorité
russe en termes en termes de à la fois
de quantité
et aussi de technologie c'était pas
aussi évident que cela et une prise de
KEF en une journée
c'était une possibilité mais mais qui
était quand même pas la plus crédible en
fait ce qui semblerait c'est que les
Russes évoluent au tout début de
l'opération vraiment dès le premier jour
vous voyez sur la carte là-haut il y a
un aéroport qui s'appelle l'aéroport de
ghostman et en fait les les Russes ont
vraiment dès le premier jour ils ont
envoyé des parents donc à 1050 km
au-delà de leur propre ligne qu'on
débarqué à l'aéroport de de costaud Mel
pardon c'était pas des parents c'est ton
hélico des forces spéciales et
là l'enjeu ça aurait été de tenir cet
aéroport d'avoir une tête de point
aérien à 20 km de Kiev et pour ensuite
faire une attaque éclair sur Kiev pour
décapiter le gouvernement c'est une
vieille
stratégie soviétique puisque c'est ce
qui avait fait les les Soviétiques en 79
en Afghanistan là ça n'a pas fonctionné
c'est que les les VDV les trophées
reportés qui ont été déployés à
agostomel on subit une contre-attaque
russe et non pas pu dès premier jour
permettent de créer un pont aérien et
donc là les Russes emploie une stratégie
plus traditionnelle c'est à dire qu'ils
ont avancé petit à petit depuis la
Biélorussie jusqu'au jusqu'à Kief
aujourd'hui il contrôle l'intégralité de
cette zone il y a à peu près 150 km et
maintenant on a un doute on voit qu'ils
sont vraiment au port de Kiev hier ils
ont fait sauter avec un missile la
l'antenne télévision de de Kiev
l'antenne télévision c'est souvent une
des premières choses que qu'on bombarde
quand quand il y a une invasion on avait
vu ça en Irak on avait vu ça dans les
guerres d'exclougoslavie c'est une sorte
de symbole et peut-être moins puissant
aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a les réseaux
sociaux donc la télévision est moins
importante mais malgré tout voilà
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
ils vont encercler Kiev et faire le
siège de KEF où est-ce que dès
maintenant il lance des opérations
contre la ville elle-même c'est on va
passer à des combats des combats urbains
ça va être très et par ailleurs est-ce
que Vladimir Poutine veut raser qui a
une peu probablement pas faire la même
chose qu'avec Rosny en Tchétchénie au
début des années 2000 parce
qu'historiquement c'est pas le même
symbole aussi pour lui la ville de café
plus enfin être reconnu ça jouerait
contre son image on a parlé
effectivement de cette autorité auprès
des Russes c'est-à-dire qu'un si rasé
Kiev pour les Russes pour la population
russe ça serait absolument terrible je
parle même pas des Ukrainiens mais là je
pense à Poutine par rapport à son
opinion publique puis effectivement donc
on a vu cette attaque vient aussi avec
cette colonne de Charde on a parlé un
peu plus tôt dans ce live absolument
cette colonne de chat quel est quel est
est-ce qu'on sait quel est son but elle
va encercler Kiev est-ce qu'elle va
essayer de
rentrer ce que je vous disais il y a les
deux possibilités on ne on ne sait pas
encore ce qu'il y a c'est qu'on sait que
mais depuis hier il y a des combats
quand même assez
assez intense au nord-ouest de tiède
donc est-ce qu'ils vont essayer de
grignoter c'est franchement trop tôt
pour le dire en tout cas aujourd'hui il
semblerait que que l'attaque principal
russe elle était à Cardiff on en a parlé
tout à l'heure donc dans l'est de
l'Ukraine oui effectivement alors on va
parler effectivement de ces autres ces
autres fronts car qui font le disait le
front nord et le front du Sud le front
du Sud alors je vais vous montrer sur la
carte que je vais retrouver qui est un
peu plus haut là-haut parce qu'il puisse
puisqu'il y a trois offensives il faut
le rappeler du Nord de l'Est et du Sud
et du Sud ça vient de la Crimée donc
c'est ici qui arrive les forces russes
et là il y a deux informations
importantes je sais pas si ton peu un
peu alors je vais actualiser la page
pour perdre mon avis je pense voilà il y
a une partie crois pas trop
les forces russes venant de Crimée et
celle venant du don-basse ce sont
rejoints pour la première fois donc ça
c'était une victoire au moins symbolique
pour les Russes et ensuite vous avez le
deuxième front de Crimée qui part vers
l'ouest et là on retrouve le nième alors
là encore le nième est vraiment
important parce qu'en fait c'est l'eau
du Nièvre qui alimente en eau la Crimée
et ça c'est un des problèmes de Vladimir
Poutine c'est qu'il y avait un problème
de sécheresse terrible en crémé parce
que les Ukrainiens tout simplement est
fermé le robinet d'eau et donc là
d'ailleurs une des premières choses
qu'ils ont faites quand ils sont montés
en honneur c'était des rouvrir le
robinet et donc là les Russes en fait on
franchi la la la la la rive du Nièvre
ils sont donc de l'autre côté vers vers
l'ouest et ils ont alors dans un premier
temps ils ont encerclé personne qui a
une très grande ville en
Ukraine et qui est une grande ville
portuaire et là il semblerait qu'il les
prises en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
annoncé les Russes le le maire de la
ville il y a hier soir disait que nous
mais enfin il semblerait que les les
Russes c'est quasiment pris la ville
c'est important parce que c'est la
première grande ville c'est la première
capitale régionale dont s'empare la
Russie et par ailleurs les combats vont
déjà au-delà les combats vont jusqu'à
ville de mikolaief qui est juste après
qui est un grand chantier naval
soviétique
et là on peut supposer qu'un des
objectifs de Poutine c'est de continuer
jusqu'à au dessert jusqu'àodessac et la
troisième ville du crâne qui a un grand
port qui est une cité balnéaire qui est
une ville assez riche qui est une ville
chargée d'histoire fondée par Catherine
II là l'opératrice de Russie en 1794
et là pour le coup ça voudrait dire une
chose ça voudrait dire que l'Ukraine n'a
plus d'accès à la mer donc on n'y est
pas encore mais en tout cas il y a une
première étape c'est que les Russes se
sont emparés ou sont sur le point de
s'emparer de Carson et par ailleurs
toujours sur le fond du Sud on voit
qu'il remonte aussi vers le nord
avec notamment alors vas-y lificat que
pas une très grande ville mais ils sont
donc tout près de zaporigia et là pour
le coup c'est une plus grande ville et
entre les deux
ils ont pris le contrôle d'une centrale
nucléaire voilà il y a pas eu de
visiblement de combat de drame mais
c'est aussi un des enjeux en Ukraine
c'est la sécurité des installations
nucléaires on avait beaucoup parlé de
Tchernobyl mais il y a pas que tchernoby
il y a aussi en Ukraine des centrales
nucléaires en activité je crois qu'il
n'y en a quatre peut-être cinq voilà
donc en particulier dans cette zone là
on parlait justement il y a deux jours
de cette fameuse stratégie qui était
d'encercler les villes c'est un peu ce
qu'on est en train de voir avec Mario
Paul finalement c'est cette stratégie
qui se valide absolument et en fait ça
peut se faire à plusieurs échelles c'est
que ça peut se faire une toute une
petite échelle locale et on peut
simplement encercler une ville c'est le
cas de de Mario Paul mais on peut aussi
créer les Russes ils appellent c'est la
stratégie des choses auront des
cocktails on a vu ça en 2014 avec des
balles CV matériaux des belles CV avec
les séparatistes mais ça peut être un
plus grand échelle on peut créer des des
poches beaucoup plus vastes et là on
peut imaginer comme il y a un front qui
qui avance vers l'est un front qui
descend depuis le nord et à fond qui
remonte depuis le sud et qu'il y a
vraiment des des combats les plus durs
se font notamment inkief mais aussi dans
l'est de l'Ukraine au niveau de carquif
on peut imaginer que les Russes vont
tenter de reproduire ça c'est à dire
d'encercler des des villes ou des zones
sachant que jusqu'à présent la stratégie
virus semblait être enfonce vers Kef
l'objectif stratégique numéro 1 au début
on ne tient pas les villes ce qu'on veut
c'est contrôler les grandes artères pour
avoir le contrôle du pays et notamment
l'objectif principal Kef là on voit
qu'il y a des prises de villes qui sont
en cours Carson mais aussi surtout car
kiff et donc là ça induit un changement
de tactique c'est-à-dire qu'on passe en
combat
urbain
on a vu qu'il y avait des tchétchen qui
avait été engagé sur le terrain
notamment à Mario Paul mais aussi on en
a vu dans les dans les alentours de Kiev
ça c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle
justement pourquoi on fait un appareil
de ce de ce renfort de de Tchétchénie
qui veut qui vient pour Poutine en quoi
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle au final
alors il y a en fait les déjà les
chaînes sont très aguerris
ils étaient engagés en
notamment et en Syrie ils ont fait
justement de la contre-insurrection et
du combat urbain donc là ils ont une
expérience qui
peut leur servir entre guillemets et
puis par ailleurs ils ont pas cet énorme
problème qui est classé un combat entre
frère entre entre frère slave les Russes
et les Ukrainiens sont culturellement
très proches et donc pour les Russes de
se battre contre les Ukrainiens c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'affreux et il
commence à y avoir des des indications
que la motivation des Russes n'est pas
gigantesque voilà et or les tchétchen
ont beaucoup moins ce problème là
et donc c'est aussi peut-être pour ça
que que les tchétchen sont envoyés en
première ligne en plus de faire le sale
boulot on a Neymar dans les commentaires
qui nous dit l'Ukraine sera finalement
coupé en deux c'est c'est une
possibilité avec ses fronts du Sud et du
Nord qui se rejoignent c'est un des
scénarios souvent on a tendance à couper
historiquement l'ukrainement 2 avec
cette partie russe plus cette partie
plus ukrainophone je pense qu'il ne faut
pas faire de
faut pas être binaire le l'Ukraine c'est
pas simplement un est russophile et un
ouest qui serait plus proche de de
l'Europe on a fait plein de papiers pour
l'expliquer c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça après dans les
scénarios
il y en a plusieurs la partition de
l'Ukraine ou fait des liens fédéraux ski
hier donc un ancien diplomate du temps
de la guerre froide à la fois russe et
ukrainien parler du risque de
l'ibanisation de l'Ukraine
la partition du pays c'est un scénario
qu'on peut envisager c'est pas le seul
il y en a plusieurs il faut rappeler
aussi que l'Ukraine est quand même un
pays qui est immense pour pour le
contrôler et ça demande énormément de de
moyens et que la Russie ne l'a pas
forcément absolument c'est à dire que si
la Russie se disait on renverse le
régime de zeninski et on met un potentat
à la place enfin dictateur qui servirait
les
encore faudrait-il qui tiennent un pays
qui en plus avait des vrais divisions
sur la question de son identité pendant
depuis son indépendance véritable en
1991 mais là d'une certaine manière
Poutine réunit les
Ukrainiens c'est qu'il est il les soude
je contrôle les combats ont lieu surtout
dans l'Est
où il y a plus de restophone laisse qui
traditionnellement appartenait à
l'Empire russe contrairement à l'ouest
du pays la grande ville de le veuf tout
à l'ouest elle apparaît pas sur la CAF
sur le sur la carte mais ça n'a jamais
été dans l'empire c'était dans l'empire
austro-hongrois c'était c'était la
Galicie donc vous voyez il y a
clairement
Poutine parvient avec son offensive
aussi à solidifier le sentiment national
ukrainien au-delà des différences
culturelles des différents historiques
on parlait vous parler justement de la
de la du on laisse on pouvait penser que
ça irait assez vite finalement sur ce
frontlest mais finalement c'est pas tant
le cas que ça car kiff est une ville qui
va en positionner que les Russes
allaient aller vite pour aller jusqu'à
la cariffe et finalement c'était un
poste n'a pas été le cas oui alors là je
voudrais faire un point d'abord sur les
faiblesses de l'armée russe qui
aujourd'hui sont pas tentes encore une
fois ça ne change pas le rappeur de
force générale qui est en faveur de la
Russie mais très clairement il y a il y
a des défauts des faiblesses de l'armée
russe qui sont vraiment visibles déjà on
nous avait vendu
une capacité de l'armée russe a été
extrêmement coordonnée autour de groupes
tactiques avec des déploiements
interhards c'est à dire que vous avez à
la fois
des chars de l'infanterie soutenu par de
l'artillerie avec de l'aviation en appui
des moyens de reconnaissance etc ça on
ne le voit nulle part ça n'existe pas
c'est-à-dire que là c'est vous avez des
colonnes de charme à côté de
l'infanterie absolument pas protégée de
l'autre pas d'appuyeriens pas de moyen
la connaissance pas de drone les Russes
n'ont même pas totalement le contrôle du
ciel aérien de contrôle du ciel les les
Ukrainiens
donc parviennent à mettre en difficulté
les Russes il y a une certitude
aujourd'hui je donnerai pas de chiffre
ça sert à rien parce que c'est trop tôt
mais il y a des des pertes russes très
importantes à la fois en homme en
matériel on voit un nombre incroyable de
de blindus qui sont calcinées ce qui est
étonnant d'ailleurs les Russes ont du
matériel extrêmement modernes depuis la
grande réforme de la fin des années 2000
là on n'a pas vu les derniers chars on a
vu beaucoup de chartes et 72 qui
dataient la fin de la guerre froide ou
du début des années 90 les T90 MS qu'on
avait vu en Syrie donc ils sont les
actuellement les meilleurs chars russes
en service on les a pas vu de la même
façon les les avions de chasse les plus
les plus récents au début les a pas vu
il y a vivement un changement de
stratégie depuis un jour ou deux parce
que les Russes se rendent compte des
limites de leur de leur opération et du
côté ukrainien sur le papier ils sont
beaucoup moins puissants mais ils ont un
certain nombre d'avantages tactiques
déjà ils sont extrêmement soudés donc ça
c'est évidemment ça c'est une importance
leur commandement a été relativement
décentralisée donc du coup les rues sont
pas pu décapiter le commandement et puis
ils tiennent et ils sont appuyés par des
quelques armements de
occidentaux qui montrent leur leur
efficacité il y a les missiles
anti-charge Aveline qui sont fournis par
les occidentaux depuis quelques années à
l'Ukraine on a vu que les charrues c'est
essayer de mettre des cages en petit
javelines au-dessus de leur tourelle
mais visiblement ça marche pas
extrêmement bien il y a des missiles
antiériens Stinger qui se porte à la à
l'épaule et là encore on a vu des se
fait rabattre des mêmes des mêmes
probablement des avions notamment des
avions des taques au sol donc ça ça
fonctionne bien et puis il y a quelque
chose dont par énormément depuis
quelques jours c'est les drones
turcstart TB2 utilisé par les ukrainiens
et qui au sol font des
fonds posent d'énormes problèmes russes
on voit des vidéos assez incroyables
avec des convois russes qui sont ciblés
par les drones avec des systèmes de
défenses anti-aériennes qui sont tapés
mais sans avoir le temps de réagir et ça
les Russes le savent depuis la Syrie que
c'est un énorme problème c'est neurones
et visiblement ils n'ont pas tiré les
leçons alors il y avait un trade d'un
chercheur très intéressant sur Twitter
visiblement les Russes on est dans le
problème de communication
et pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
visiblement ils n'ont pas tous des
radios militaires protégés ils ont des
radios publiques sur lesquels on
pourrait civil et donc ils sont très
facilement non seulement à cas donc ils
n'entendent rien ils sont c'est brouillé
et par ailleurs interceptable c'est à
dire que les Ukrainiens arrivent à
intercepter les ordres des Russes les
conversations des Russes et donc du coup
il y a un énorme problème de
coordination des forces il y a un énorme
problème de logistique voilà donc pour
les Russes vraiment ça me manque
des faiblesses qui sont indubitables
après encore une fois je répète ça ne
change pas le rapport de force pour
l'instant sur le terrain et d'ailleurs
on le voit bien avec les avec les
quartiers il y a une inventé russe qui
est qui est réelle et je donne un
parallèle historique on dit beaucoup oui
les Russes
devaient arriver à Kieff en une journée
ou en deux jours si on prend par exemple
la guerre d'Irak des Américains en 2003
il n'était pas en une journée à Bagdad
et il y a eu des comparaisons de de
chercheurs qui ont été faites ça
n'avance pas tellement moins vite que
que la guerre d'Irak alors que l'Irak
est un pays plus petit
et que par ailleurs l'armée des
États-Unis c'est pas comparable avec
l'armée russe voilà pour des raisons
évidentes en termes de budget il y a un
rapport de je peux dire de bêtises mais
je crois que c'est un rapport de 1 à 7
entre les deux très bien donc on a
Charles Martel qui me demande de
répondre à certaines questions du chat
ce que je vais faire effectivement jar
jarvings qui demande la livraison
d'armes à l'armée une Ukrainienne
arrive-t-elle pas trop tard et comment
l'acheminer finalement parce qu'on parle
beaucoup de de ces armes qui vont être
acheminées ce qu'on sait comment on
comment cela peut être possible il y a
des informations on sait dans les
grandes lignes c'est-à-dire que voilà ça
passe évidemment par des états
frontaliers notamment la Pologne après
évidemment on a on n'a pas le détail
voilà on peut imaginer des avions de
transport qui se pose en Pologne ensuite
voilà ça rentre par l'ouest de l'Ukraine
qui est assez stratégique et c'est à peu
près les
principaux armements c'est ce dont je
vous ai déjà parlé et notamment ce qui a
été annoncé ce matin c'est l'envoi
supplémentaire de de drones TV2 et donc
ça ça mais encore une fois il y a il y a
pas de
de
d'armes magiques il y a pas de miracle
donc ça ne a priori ça changera pas
voilà sauf s'il y avait des grands
événements politiques ou voilà mais la
dynamique actuellement elle est quand
même en faveur de Moscou qui progresse
effectivement est-ce que il y a tout de
même un risque d'enlisement tu parlais
oui il y a un risque dans l'islement
réel à plusieurs égards déjà on peut
imaginer donc une
campagne militaire qui dure des semaines
pour prendre le pays et donc là ça
serait en fait quand on parle
d'enlisement c'est aussi une victoire
mais à quel coût c'est à dire que si
c'est des dizaines de milliers de morts
de soldats russes morts pour Vladimir
Poutine c'est absolument terrible et
politiquement c'est-à-dire qu'il va être
extrêmement affaibli et puis l'autre
lisement et l'une des questions c'est
est-ce que les Ukrainiens même si
l'armée ukrainienne était défaite
est-ce que les Ukrainiens arrivent
à continuer les combats
mais sous une forme de guérilla c'est à
dire on passerait d'une guerre
conventionnelle de haute intensité
à une guerre d'insurrection et de contre
insurrection
clause de petites guerres est-ce qu'on
va passer d'une grande guerre une petite
guerre et le problème d'une petite
guerre les Américains l'ont très bien le
savent très bien en Irak on avait gagné
ce temps ça dure extrêmement longtemps
et c'est une guerre qu'on ne gagne
jamais et donc c'est la question qu'on
posait tout à l'heure est-ce que les
russes auraient les moyens de tenir un
pays comme l'Ukraine c'est pas sûr du
tout c'est pour ça que les les scénarios
politiques possibles de sortie de crise
ils sont assez nombreux et franchement
on peut pas mettre de probabilité sur
ces scénarios
on a Charles Martel qui nous reparle de
cette colonne de tank qui qui arrive a
priori vers Kiev est-ce que l'armée
ukrainienne avait moyen de la pilonner
de la de l'attaquer par les airs
alors c'est l'une des questions c'est
c'est ce que c'est drone notamment
pourraient infliger des dégâts à cette
colonne de chat c'est possible on l'a vu
ces derniers jours
après la réduire un néon probablement
pas et peut-être que justement les
Russes les Américains ont dit que les
Russes étaient à l'arrêt là mais c'est
aussi pour l'homme parce que les Russes
sont très attention
essaye de se coordonner de voilà
d'essayer de ne pas répéter les mêmes
erreurs que ces derniers jours
on a aussi une application sur les sur
les sur les bilans sur les sur les
bilans qui elles parlent de 356 villes
les forceraient les forces russes aussi
donnent des bilans c'est bilans il faut
les prendre avec précaution comme
d'habitude il faut les prendre avec
précaution et on peut craindre
malheureusement c'est dire ce que disait
l'ONU de hier que le les bilans réels
soit soit supérieur en tout cas pour les
les bilans civils et puis pour les
bilans militaires la Russie ne donne pas
de chiffres puisqu'elle a dans sa
minimiser la guerre c'est la stratégie
de com de Poutine elle semble pas très
bien marché du côté ukrainien il
communique beaucoup on a parlé de 4000
5000 soldats russes tu es blessé ou
arrêté
où est la réalité on sait pas trop je
pense que il faut aussi regarder les
précédents de guerre on entend beaucoup
ces derniers jours qui a pas eu de
grandes guerres en Europe depuis 1991
mais c'est faux il y a eu les guerres
d'Aix Yougoslavie et les guerres
Yougoslavie ont fait plus de 100.000
morts voilà
or là potentiellement c'est
un pays qui est beaucoup plus grand que
la Bosnie que la Serbie que voilà donc
peuplé aussi et puis peuplé il faut
avoir ces ordres de grandeur là en tête
ou les ordres de grandeur donnés par
l'enu sur le nombre de réfugiés qu'on
pourrait avoir plus de plus de 5
millions possiblement on n'en sait rien
aujourd'hui les chiffres c'est plus de
500 000 c'est déjà énorme effectivement
vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr à continuer
à poser vos questions on va essayer d'y
répondre le mieux possible il y avait il
y a une autre question qui se pose aussi
c'est sur le front du Nord mais
peut-être plutôt vers l'Ouest c'est
l'ajout des forces biélorusse qui
pourrait peut-être changer la donne
quelque part oui alors on n'a pas
on n'a aucune conformation de cela en
fait depuis plusieurs jours on voit des
convois militaires vraiment dans dans
l'ouest de la Biélorussie se former
et il semblerait que ce soit notamment
des troupes biélorusses donc l'une des
questions c'est est-ce que la Russie
veut avec son allié biélorus ouvrir un
nouveau front le plus à l'ouest possible
et foncé vers les notamment vers la
ville de Le Vif qui est la grande ville
de l'ouest ukrainien
je crois que c'est trop tôt pour le dire
mais c'est bien sûr une possibilité en
tout cas c'est une crainte exprimée
publiquement
par à la fois des sources de
renseignement américain enfin via des
sciences politiques mais
américaine et ukrainienne mais cette
stratégie elle serait dangereuse aussi
puisque on arriverait vraiment à des
pays qui sont dans l'OTAN et cette
fois-ci ça serait effectivement la à la
frontière de l'auto notamment la
frontière
polonaise donc évidemment c'est alors
mais d'ailleurs puisqu'on parle de la
Biélorussie ça c'est un point qu'il faut
vraiment garder à l'esprit je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez mais donc il y
avait eu la réélection de Lucas and Co
le président dictateur
biélorus et une élection qui avait été
complètement truquée l'année dernière et
pour la première fois il y avait des
très grandes manifestations Biélorussie
qui avait vraiment menacé la survie du
régime de lucaschenko
et le cacher une coque avait toujours
joué un jeu très trouble entre les
Américains et les Russes c'est-à-dire
qu'à chaque fois que Poutine essayait de
mettre son emprise sur la ville aussi
d'aller voir les Américains etc il
jouait l'un contre l'autre et ben là il
avait plus le choix c'est que comme son
régime était vraiment affaibli il allait
voir Poutine dans les 10 ans j'ai besoin
de toi et donc ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui si on élargit un peu le
spectre c'est qu'on avait Vladimir
Poutine qui pour la première fois
depuis longtemps
à la main sur la Biélorussie et il faut
voir que
l'intervention militaire en Ukraine de
la Russie
ne pourrait pas du tout être la même
s'il y avait pas la possibilité pour les
forces le russe de l'entrée par la
Biélorussie parce que par la Biélorussie
qui a fait à 150 km
si en revanche on rentre par l'est là où
en plus les défenses ukrainiennes
étaient mieux préparées bah oui parce
que comme la guerre de 2014 avait été
menée dans l'Est ukrainien c'est là où
il y avait les défenses les plus les
plus importantes et donc cette vraie
alliance stratégique entre la
Biélorussie et la Russie c'est quelque
chose qui est ça changeait donne et qui
a été matérialisé on en a peu parlé
parce qu'on est évidemment focalisé sur
l'Ukraine mais il y a eu un référendum
en Biélorussie pour réviser la
Constitution et donc la
Biélorussie abandonne à la fois ça
nucléarisation qui avait été actée en
1994 et puis son statut de neutralité
diplomatique donc là il y a même une
sorte d'axe qui se crée qui se crée
contre contre le temps ce qu'il faut
vraiment réaliser c'est que là il y a un
rideau de fer quoi qu'il arrive il y a
un rideau de fer qui est tombé sur l'est
de l'Europe voilà est-ce que on en
parlait aussi un peu tout à l'heure on a
une autre question là-dessus c'est une
victoire russe est-ce que c'est toujours
inéluctable est-ce que ça va est-ce
qu'on peut se dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres issue pour l'instant
une victoire militaire russe et le plus
probable encore une fois la question
c'est à quel prix
en revanche une victoire politique une
victoire stratégique de Vladimir Poutine
non seulement elle est beaucoup moins
probable mais elle est même extrêmement
improbable il s'est lancé dans une
aventure qui est quand même un pari
extrêmement extrêmement
osé
il a franchi une ligne rouge et est-ce
que le régime de la Vladimir Poutine va
pouvoir encaisser cela c'est pas évident
et ce que les ressoutiennent la guerre
je n'en suis pas sûr alors même que la
majorité des Russes sont probablement
d'accord avec les critiques que Vladimir
Poutine faisait à l'endroit de l'OTAN de
l'avancée vers l'aile de l'OTAN etc etc
ça oui le constat général oui mais en
revanche la décision d'envahir l'Ukraine
ça à mon avis les Russes non il y avait
un texte de je le cite parce qu'il y
avait un texte de sol génit de Sin qui
est pourtant avait une vision
extrêmement pense laviste de la Russie
il considérait comme Poutine que la
ville Russie que l'Ukraine était hétérus
mais il y a un texte qui est à la fin de
sa vie normalement je disais jamais
jamais je n'enverrai mon fils se battre
face à un Ukrainien et je pense que
c'est là si vous voulez la ligne rouge
que Poutine a franchi et qui n'est pas
forcément incompatible avec la vision
générale russe on va dire
anti-occidental en tout cas avec une
très grande méfiance à l'endroit de
l'Occident oui parce qu'il est quand
même énormément de manifestation en
Russie alors quelque chose de très rare
on t'attend pas des énormes
rassemblements mais ça a quand même pris
une certaine ampleur là-bas ça a pris
une certaine ampleur alors pour
l'instant ça
pas du tout
capable de renverser le pouvoir russe
mais il y a eu des manifestations des
gens évidemment extrêmement courageux
parce que je crois qu'il y a eu 6000
arrestations enfin c'est énorme
donc les Russes qui faisaient ça ça va
être très bien le
danger qu'ils encourait
mais est-ce que ça va
vraiment changer la donne je sais pas
hier raconté que les les Russes sont
quand même traumatisées par par la
dissolution de l'Union soviétique et la
décennie des années 90 qui a suivi c'est
une vraiment c'était le chaos en Russie
et un chaos notamment enfin politique
mais aussi économique est-ce que les
Russes ont envie de revivre ça
c'est-à-dire de
de se risquer à finalement une un après
Poutine qui soit
un peu instable pas sûr mais c'est pas
pour autant qu'ils sont favorables à la
guerre en Ukraine loin de là on a yogi
qui nous pose une question sur les sur
les sur les drones Turcs dont on parlait
tout à l'heure c'est gran turc on va
peut-être répéter ce qu'on a ce qu'on
disait mais c'est quelque chose qui
change de la donne alors pas sur le plan
général mais qui ralentit vraiment les
forces russes oui c'est ce je pense que
c'est le meilleur résumé c'est à dire
qu'aucun armement en soins ne peut
changer le cours d'une d'une guerre
en revanche oui ça donne un avantage
tactique aux ukrainien qui est évident
et qui le permet d'exploiter déjà une
très belle résistance une résistance
globale qui dépend pas juste d'une
technologie en particulier on parlait
des des négociations aussi pour pour
l'issue de ce conflit qui pourrait se
passer diplomatiquement par des
négociations il y en a eu ces derniers
jours est-ce que on a des nouvelles de
ces négociations est-ce qu'elles ont
est-ce qu'elles ont des chances
d'aboutir rapidement
moi j'ai retenu trois déclarations déjà
les Ukrainiens qui se disent
ouverts sur la question de la
neutralisation de l'Ukraine
neutralisation au sens diplomatique
c'est-à-dire que serait indépendantes et
son indépendance serait garantie à la
fois par la Russie et par le temps c'est
ce qu'on appelle le modèle finlandais
sauf que le modèle finlandais
aujourd'hui le résultat c'est que les
finlandais veulent rentrer dans le temps
donc mais en tout cas la partie
ukrainienne qui joue jusqu'à maintenant
ne voulait pas en entendre parler
est prêt on entend parler le deuxième
son de cloche
c'est que le conseiller le porte-parole
de
du Kremlin petscoff a déclaré hier qu'il
considèrent ski comme enfin le
gouvernement qui comme le gouvernement
légitime de café ça veut pas dire qu'il
y a pas un plan de renversement de zen
qui est encore une fois mais en terme
diplomatique
ça veut dire qu'il y a la base d'une
négociation possible après
le problème c'est qu'on ne s'est
toujours pas quel est l'objectif
stratégie de vladir petit non ou la
matérialisation de cette stratégie on a
toujours un doute il sait entretenir ce
doute c'est vraiment dans sa culture
effectivement
le rapport avec les avec les avec les
Européens la réaction de l'Europe
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait et qu'est-ce
qu'elle peut encore faire ce qui est
impressionnant c'était au départ la
sidération européenne
face à cette grande guerre qui est
déclenchée dans l'Europe au sens de
cantine continent pas dans le temps pas
dans l'Union européenne mais dans
l'Europe donc une sidération dans un
premier temps
et ensuite une une réaction extrêmement
vive et je vais prendre juste un exemple
c'était le chef d'état-major de l'armée
de terre allemande qui le jour de
l'invasion donc c'était jeudi dernier
sort un message complètement
catastrophique en disant écoutez on est
à sec on n'a rien on n'est pas capable
de faire face à des menaces de la sorte
psychologiquement et quand même très
étonnant au moment où un pays on en a un
autre c'est pas le moment de déclarer
voilà c'est étonnant mais quelques jours
après les Allemands switch complètement
et décide alors on reparle en Allemagne
de relancer l'industrie du nucléaire
civile
ils ont annoncé 100 milliards de dollars
cette année pour les pour les bouger
c'est absolument énorme le budget
militaire de la France et dans les 40
milliards donc là c'est en un coup 100
milliards et puis ensuite aller vers 70
milliards par an donc si vous voulez ça
aussi une remitérisation de l'Allemagne
aujourd'hui on a on a coutume de dire
que les deux seuls réarmés en Europe
c'est la France et le Royaume-Uni
donc là c'est un signe important et par
ailleurs surtout le grand signe européen
c'était la décision de vendre enfin de
donner des armes létale
à l'Ukraine et ça c'était une
politiquement c'est une décision très
forte et on a vu
que des pays vraiment qui avait une
culture pacifiste si rallier la Suède
par exemple la Suède j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure de la Finlande qui qui se pose
la question de son accession à l'OTAN
donc ce sont des signaux très importants
maintenant je voudrais dire quand même
que le la phrase qu'on entend un peu
c'est que notamment l'Europe de la
défense l'Europe puissance aurait plus
avancé
il y avait un militaire français qui dit
ça ce matin sur RTL et plus avancée en
trois jours qu'en 20 ans
faudrait quand même attendre de voir la
suite parce qu'il y a d'autres personnes
qui tiennent un autre discours qui
disent attention on va réarmer oui mais
avec quels armes
peut-être avec des armes américaines les
Allemands ont reparlé d'un achat de F35
américain
donc si à la fin c'est pour se retrouver
avec plus d'armes américaines est-ce que
vraiment ça sera un grand pas pour
l'autonomie stratégique du continent par
ailleurs ce que ça a remis en avant
c'est l'OTAN
voilà le temps qui était déclaré en mort
Macron parlait d'une mort cérébrale de
l'Alliance etc là il y a pas du tout de
mort Cérébra le contraire il y a une
sorte de réflexe
c'était Hubert Védrine qui avait une
analyse très intéressante il disait le
que le monstre Poutine enfin le Poutine
de 2022 c'est finalement les Russes et
les Occidentaux qui l'ont co fabriqué
c'est un peu comme une sorte de Mons de
Frankenstein
mais d'une certaine manière Poutine
indubitablement n'ayant peur de l'OTAN
là en faisant ça il a réactivé le temps
et donc c'est tous ces débats sur est-ce
que l'OTAN depuis 1991 a eu un rôle
dysplasif protecteur pour les pays qui
l'ont qui sont entrés dans le temps et
qui le souhaitaient pour des raisons
historiques évidentes ou est-ce que ça
participait
qu'aux allemand à une montée aux
extrêmes à une escale à une escalade
parce que les rues sont fassent sont
inquiets et du coup c'est ce qu'on
appelle le DM de sécurité et là il y a
une il y a un vrai débat
c'est probablement pas
aujourd'hui le moment de se le poser
mais il faut bien se dire que cette
guerre en Ukraine c'est quand même une
guerre qui s'inscrit dans une liste dans
une histoire qui est ouvert depuis 1991
et qui est quand même l'incapacité de
l'Europe
à bâtir une relation
saine avec la Russie et finalement
l'Ukraine comme toujours dans son
histoire depuis des siècles
se retrouvent le territoire et
aujourd'hui depuis un mouvement récent
depuis le 19e une nation qui se retrouve
prise entre tous les empires et
aujourd'hui l'Ukraine on est là
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait
t'en parler tu en parler et ça c'est un
nouveau paradigme qui est en train de se
créer en Europe c'est un nouveau
paradigme je pense que là-dessus il y a
une quasi uneanimité pour décrire
quelque chose qu'on
sentait déjà mais qui va s'accélérant
c'est alors on peut appeler ça une
nouvelle guerre froide on peut appeler
ça un nouveau rideau de fer qui tombe à
l'aise de l'Europe avec des acteurs qui
sont un peu différents du côté de
l'ouest on retrouve
globalement les mêmes acteurs en
revanche à l'est
est-ce que est en train de se former un
bloc Russie Chine voir Iran c'est l'un
des puissances
antioxydantales
révisionniste on emploie beaucoup ce mot
c'est à dire qu'on une autre
vision de l'histoire et qui veulent
réécrire l'histoire qui aurait été
écrite par les Occidentaux puisque
c'est la vieille phrase malheureux
vaincue c'est toujours le vainqueur qui
écrit l'histoire à la fin c'est c'est
des nations justement la Chine mise au
banc par les autres par les États-Unis
et qui pourrait en profiter pour
s'allier avec l'Ukraine
excusez-moi mais on en est pas non plus
encore là non c'est une alliance pas sur
la question ukrainienne sur la question
ukrainienne la Chine a une
reste vraiment
loin de ça d'ailleurs elle a pas
soutenue ouvertement là aussi elle a pas
voté contre au Conseil de sécurité mais
elle sait elle s'est abstenue
et elle ne coupe pas du tout les ponts
avec l'Ukraine
elle elle a pas non plus envie
qu'on remette en cause le principe de
souveraineté des États on sait que le
séparatisme en Chine fait partie des
trois grandes menaces
identifiées par les par l'État
communiste donc ils ont peur du
séparatisme donc l'intangibilité des
frontières pour eux c'est quelque chose
d'important alors évidemment il triche
sur Taïwan mais très simplement c'est
que officiellement enfin de leur point
de vue Taïwan c'est à eux c'est eux donc
ils ne remettraient pas en cause les
frontières de Taïwan s'il venait
intervenir un tuning c'est évidemment
très hypocrite mais c'est ainsi merci
beaucoup Alexis ont peut-être faire un
dernier petit point de la situation sur
les sur les sur les grandes manoeuvres à
suivre aujourd'hui surtout et dans les
prochains jours c'est surtout car kiff
on en parler alors bah il y a car kiff
parce que là il y a eu ces débarquements
de de troupes aéroportée et en général
les troupes aéroportées ces troupes
avancées c'est celle qui viennent avant
en amont et puis ensuite il y a les
trous régulières qui arrivent derrière
donc est-ce que la la bataille de karkiv
comment à proprement parler c'est
possible et même question
acquief il y a c'est qu'on voit
gigantesques de trop bruses de blindus
de charrus qui sont au bord de la ville
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire
est-ce que ils cherchent à encercler
complètement Kiev on voit que là on le
voit mal mais keV n'est pas complètement
cerclé ou est-ce que ils essayent de
rentrer directement dans dans la ville
avec tous les risques que ça représente
et puis sur le fond du Sud il faut
vraiment observer la bataille de Mario
Paul Mario Paul à l'Est qui est encerclé
et puis à l'ouest est-ce que l'avancée
russe va continuer est-ce que ils vont
encercler et prendre Michael Life et
puis du coup il y a Odessa on parle
depuis des jours d'un débarquement russe
avec des navires amphibie à proximité de
dessin ça va être une des une des
grandes questions de de ces jours
prochains pour couper l'accès à la mer à
l'Ukraine mais c'est encore on y est pas
encore on n'est pas encore très bien
merci beaucoup merci à vous tous d'avoir
été avec nous sur ce direct et d'avoir
suivi ce live vous avez été très
nombreux à commenter on espère que vous
avez pu poser toutes vos questions et
qu'on vous a bien répondu continuez de
suivre la formation sur le Figaro notre
direct qui est à jour tout est dernières
informations vous trouverez merci en
tout cas Alexis merci et merci au
service infographie qui met les jours
les cartes à jour en permanence
effectivement merci beaucoup au service
d'infographie sur ces différentes cartes
qui nous permettent aussi de faire ses
directs et on vous donne rendez-vous à
bientôt pour d'autres live sur Figaro
live